l'astv loana elle est absente hier
malheureusement pour des ennuis de santé
on pense fort à elle d'ailleurs et hier
soir steve et a répondu à ceux qui les
accusent de ne pas aider la star c'est
vrai qu'est ce que vous dites à ces gens
qui disent que vous n'aidez pas loana
amoureux quand on vient en aide dans
quels cas quelqu'un on n'est pas obligé
de le faire devant les caméras tu as
raison je suis moi je suis pas exposer
comme ça ma vie tout le temps partout
si je fais si je fais de bon coeur et
parce que j'avais beaucoup d'estimé pour
elle mais en aucun cas je dois faire ça
devant les caméras ou voilà ma vie
privée ne regarde pas les gens août a
nommé eric jacquet moment oui julien
imposé trois fois mon aide mais c'est
vrai que je fait discrètement alors loi
woerth et la grande la grande absente du
première série sur les réseaux sociaux
et aux loana ou et luan a forcément
loana elle est là le corona et la pauvre
à la ccrb actuellement 1 à coronas slr
jory douar est ce que tu avais reçu des
nouvelles de loana toit après non non
non non pas par le sol et sur le groupe
oui voilà sur le podium mais sinon non
non moi j'ai pas mal je suis et je
suivais un peu sa cape et des devoirs
voilà toutes les difficultés qu'elle a
vu ou pas la question et pax penny ou
pas c'est toujours malheureux de voir
quelqu'un sans foncé sur moi ce qui m'a
peiné c'est que je les dis hier soir je
reste persuadé que c'est pas en allant à
la télévision ou qu'elle va s'en sortir
pour moi c'est un moment il faut tirer
un trait un certain temps at your daddy
c'est pas trop alors il va t en guerre
chez nous pour toi c'est une mauvaise
idée ouais mais à mort moi quand je te
le dis franchement vierge de vue là je
me suis dit mon dieu quoi c'est pas
comme ça qu'elle va s'en sortir
elle pense que c'est à travers la télé
qui est d'abord une rédemption mais ça
n'existe pas il ya part d'histoire comme
ça c'est à leurs gains tout est bien
tout à fait d'accord avec jean edouard
non parce que je pense que c'est pas
aussi violent comme médiatisation que le
loft le loft elle était vue par 12
millions de personnes pendant la finale
c'est devenu une énorme star là c'est
pas en faisant un plateau de thé pmp
qu'elle va redevenir une star elle vient
bon comme non non c'est pas par rapport
à ça c'est une fois qu'elle a fait
l'émission
les trois quarts des choses que moi j'ai
lu sur les réseaux c'est à la plus une
ratiches regarder sa bouche c'est
rageant elles sont affreusement méchant
était arrivé ça fait sacrément
d'audience pour que quand aider précise
quand il sous médicaments tu vas dire
les commentaires et tu regardes ce qu'on
dit c'est vrai que c'était l'horreur
honteux ces seuils sont violents et
clients les rêves de finir donc au final
tu utilises tu dis non mais à quoi bon
quoi autant qu'en mai
si la pâte en mai ce qui est vrai c'est
que loana c'est une situation très
compliquée à résoudre ça vous êtes
d'accord avec ça quand même
c'est bien sûr mais c'est pour ça que
six allemands c'est la résoudre c'est
prendre du temps aux métis comment les
princes moment avec c'est ça la question
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la plus personne
autour d'elle que c'est compliqué
d'estivé de veiller à c'est son choix
oui c'est ce que tu dis c'est compliqué
de la contacter de la joint de l'avoir
de l'aider mais voilà c'est ce trait
évidemment il a raison ça lui aussi moi
j'avais vu les sms que steve est envoyé
à loana je vous l'avais dit d'ailleurs
et on voit bien que c'était vraiment une
lune il vraiment proposer ont tous et
elle n'a jamais répondu
donc et même ici il faut choisir les
bonnes personnes pour s'entourer dans
les boîtes de nuit
c'est ça c'est venez chez moi au mans ça
serait pas là la fête quoi c'était c'est
sûr qu'à part manger de l'ariège c'est
les 24 heures de la rillette du mans
quand je reste convaincu de l'ariège
j'adore le mans et on embrasse ailleurs
est ou non ils ont créé mais l'équipe de
foot non mais c'est vrai que c'est bien
bravo merci bravo
isabelle en métal et chéri justin les
boîtes de nuit qu'on trouve les
meilleurs soutiens
merci oui je sais que vous vous y allait
tous les soirs et ça ne l'a pas fait du
bien